WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SIX WE'RE HAVING A
SPECIAL HEARING WE ARE IN
RESOLUTION HAVEN'T YES AND WE
HAVE SEVERAL I WILL NOTE THAT
IT OF NUMBER FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
OR HR FORTY FOUR IS. THAT WILL
TAKE THAT UP WE HAVE A QUORUM
START WITH OUR ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHT. ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND TAKE YOUR STAFF FOR
THE WONDERFUL ANALYSIS AS WELL
AJ ARE TWENTY ONE WOULD DECLARE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT FOR HR FORTY
THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH A COMMISSION TO
STUDY AND DEVELOP PROPOSALS FOR
REPARATIONS TO DESCENDANTS OF
SLAVES PERSONS IN THE UNITED
STATES I WANT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR THIS SIMPLY PUTS A RECORD
TO SUPPORT A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD STUDY.
THE ISSUE OF REPARATIONS.
FURTHERMORE THIS RESOLUTION
FORMALLY APOLOGIZES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMPLICITY AND
FURTHERING THE PRACTICE OF ALL
FLAVOR IN CALIFORNIA. EXACTLY
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS AGO THIS
MONTH THE FIRST SHIP CARRYING
TWENTY ENSLAVED AFRICANS
ARRIVED IN THE COLONY OF
VIRGINIA. THESE TWENTY PEOPLE
WERE THE FIRST OF AN ESTIMATED
FOUR MILLION AFRICANS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS THAT WOULD BECOME
ENSLAVED IN THE COLONIES AND
THE UNITED STATES. THIS
ESTIMATE DOES NOT INCLUDE
COUNTLESS NATIVE AMERICANS THEY
WERE VIRTUALLY IN SLAVE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES IN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AS WE
CONSIDER THE MAGNITUDE OF
SLAVERY IN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE IMPORTANCE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE PRACTICE WAS NOT ONLY
A PRIVATE ACT. THE INSTITUTION
OF SLAVERY. WAS
CONSTITUTIONALLY AND
STATUTORILY SANCTIONED BY LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA DESPITE
THE ADMISSION AS A SO CALLED
FREE STATE WE PERMITTED THE
VIRTUAL TRAFFICKING AND
ENSLAVEMENT OF NATIVE AMERICANS
AND EARLY YEARS OF STATEHOOD.
CALIFORNIA WAS ALSO VERY
ACCOMMODATING AND COMPLICIT IN
FURTHERING THE PRACTICE OF
SLAVERY IN AND OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE BY PASSING ITS OWN
VERSION OF THE FUGITIVE SLAVE
ACT. AND THIS PRACTICE REMAINED
UNIMPEDED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY UNTIL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE WHEN THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
WAS. ABOLISHED SLAVERY. DESPITE
THE ABOLITION OF SLAVERY
AFRICAN AMERICANS BECAME THE
SUBJECT OF TARGETED
DISCRIMINATORY POLICIES THAT
SOUGHT TO MAINTAIN BASICALLY
THE STATUS QUO. LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ENACTED
POLICIES AND PRACTICES FROM
SHARECROPPING CONVICT LEASING
REDLINING RESTRICTIVE HOUSING
COVENANTS AN EQUAL EDUCATION
PUNITIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MEASURE AND OTHERS WHICH
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
AFRICAN AMERICANS. BECAUSE OF
THIS TARGETED DISCRIMINATION
AND EFFECTS STEMMING FROM THE
PRACTICE. OF SLAVERY AFRICAN
AMERICANS CONTINUE TO FACE
DEBILITATING SOMETIMES ECONOMIC
EDUCATION AND HEALTH HARDSHIPS
FROM WHICH RECOVERY HAS BEEN
DAUNTING AND OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE
AS WE CONTINUE TO PUT.
OBSTACLES IN THE WAY OF TRUE
EQUALITY. WHAT SLAVERY WAS
FORMALLY ABOLISHED OVER HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AGO ITS LEGACY ON
THE SUBSEQUENT GENERATIONS ARE
CLEAR JUST AS GOVERNMENT HAD A
ROLE IN ENABLING THE
ENSLAVEMENT DISCRIMINATION OF
AN ENTIRE POPULATION IT HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO EXPLORE
AVENUES OF REDRESS FOR THOSE
WHO EXPERIENCE THE HISTORICAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS
INSTITUTION. THE. ASIAN ARE FOR
ME THE COMMISSION BE REPARATION
PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
ACTED DOES EXACTLY THAT HR
FORTY WOULD ESTABLISH A FEDERAL
COMMISSION TO STUDY THE
LEGACIES OF SLAVERY IN OUR
COUNTRY AND TO DEVELOP
PROPOSALS FOR REPARATIONS TO
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PERSONS
IN THE UNITED STATES OUR
COUNTRY CAN'T BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE INCREDIBLE RACIAL
INEQUITIES STILL PREVALENT IN
OUR SOCIETY TODAY UNTIL WEEKS
AFTER WORK TOWARDS REDRESS OF
OUR COUNTRY'S ORIGINAL SIN I
THINK THE TIMING IS PERFECT IN
ADDRESSING THIS AND THE-
RESOLUTION AND TAKE KNOWLEDGE
THAT UNTIL WE ARE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES. AND OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR OUR GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS
ABOUT WHAT WE DID IN THIS
COUNTRY AND INTEL WE REALLY
COME TO TERMS WITH THAT AND
ADDRESS IT THAT WE WILL NEVER
HAVE THE TYPE OF DEMOCRACY AND
THE TYPE OF COUNTRY THAT WE
OFTEN SUGGEST WE DO SET WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY FROM ABOUT THANK
YOU ARE THEIR. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WAS CAR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOW I
THINK THE AUTHOR BRING THIS
FORWARD AND I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF OF THE REALLY EXCELLENT
STAFF FOR THE GOES IN A LOT OF
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND IN
PARTICULAR. YOU KNOW BUT IT'S
ALL IT'S REFERRED TO OFTENTIMES
OF THE OF THE TERM FORTY ACRES
AND A MULE AND REFERRING TO
THAT AND STAFF OR GENERAL
SHERMAN SPECIAL ORDER. ORDER
FIFTEEN. WHICH WAS A VERY I
MEAN IN THEM AND THAT IN THAT
MOMENT IN TIME WHEN YOU HAD
THE- POWER TO DO SO ON THE
GROUND. AS THESE PLANTATION BE
ABANDONED. TO HAVE THE WISDOM
IS INVOLVED WHO BETTER TO GIVE
THE LAND TO. THEM TO THOSE
FORMERLY ENSLAVED AND WAS
GIVING THESE ORDERS OUT IN
SOUTH CAROLINA GEORGIA. AND
THEN OF COURSE PRESIDENT
JOHNSON GETS IN THERE AND NOT
ONLY REMOVES THAT ORDER BUT IN
THE SUBSEQUENT YEARS ALL. RIGHT.
SALAS BUT JIM AND THEN THE
SUBSEQUENT. OF CODIFICATION AND
LAW OF FOR THE SECOND CLASS
CITIZENSHIP OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS EVEN TO THE MODERN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND SO
I THINK THAT ALL OF US
CERTAINLY THAT SUPPORT THIS
BELIEVE JUST AS YOU DO I'M SURE
THAT. WAS A LONG TIME COMING
AND A LOT OF THE- THE RACIAL
ANIMUS AND ISSUES WE'RE DEALING
WITH RACE. PARTLY IS ABOUT IS
IN PART BECAUSE WE NEVER DEALT
WITH THE RACE ISSUE AND IN
PARTICULAR DEALT WITH. THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF AND A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR. WHAT WE DID
TO THE ENSLAVED AFTER EVERYBODY
HERE AND HOPE TO ONLY TO MODERN
DAY AFTER AMERICANS WERE STILL.
GET THEIR PRODUCT IN A MEAL. SO
I THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS. THANK YOU AND WE'RE GOING
TO PAUSE AND TAKE. ON. HOW YOU
GONZALEZ PRESENT HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
NORRIS REYES. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER OBERNOLTE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO. PART MY
VOICE TOO MUCH TIME ON THE
PHONE. YEAH THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE RESOLUTIONS WHERE 95% OF
WHAT YOU SAID I COULDN'T
COMPLETE AGREEMENT WITH AND I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THAT LAST 5%
BECAUSE THAT. NO REALLY OP TYPE
WHEN I SAY YES I IT MEANS I'M
I'M AGREEING TO EVERYTHING AND
I WANT TO BRING UP SPECIFICALLY
THE TOPIC OF REPARATIONS
BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF THE FOR
WHAT FOR ME IS THE GRAY AREA.
AND IN THE RESOLUTION TO TALK
ABOUT THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT
IN THE REPARATIONS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE JAPANESE
INTERNEES DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
WHICH I THINK WAS VERY
APPROPRIATE BUT- THAT IS JUST A
BIG TURN FOR REPARATIONS TO
THE- TERMS OF SLAVERY BUT I
MEAN THERE'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES BECAUSE- WHEN. THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT WAS PASSED.
THERE WERE MANY OF THE JAPANESE
INTERNEES THAT WERE STILL ALIVE
AND SO WAS A DIRECT
COMPENSATION PAID TO THAT
WHERE. ARE RIGHT NOW THE LAST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN SLAVE I
BELIEVE DIED NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR SPOKE. A TO ME THERE'S A
BIG DISCONNECT CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT WHY YOU THINK. THAT
EXAMPLE PLIES WHY REPARATIONS
ARE APPROPRIATE. SO THAT I
WANTED TO BE CLEAR THAT WE'RE
WE'RE NOT. AS A BODY IT MAY
HAVE PERSONAL VIEWS OBVIOUSLY
ABOUT FORTY ACRES AND A MULE WE
ACTUALLY WE'RE DOING THE MATH
ON IT. BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
BILL IS RIGHT THIS BILL
SUPPORTS THE COMMISSION THAT
WILL STUDY WHETHER THESE TYPES
OF QUESTIONS. WE PLACED IN THE
EXAMPLE OF JAPANESE INTERNMENT
BECAUSE IT'S THE MOST MODERN
DAY EXAMPLE WE HAVE OF COURSE
YOU KNOW THAT THE FURTHER WE
GET AWAY FROM THE INSTITUTION
HAVING NOT ADDRESSED SLAVERY OF
COURSE EVERYBODY DIES. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THE EFFECTS OF
WHAT HAPPENED DIED AND I THINK
ABOUT IN IN MY OWN FAMILY. MY
DAUGHTER WHO IS A DESCENDANT OF
AFRICAN SLAVES. AFRICAN
ENSLAVED PEOPLE AND IN HIGH
SCHOOL HAVING TO HAVE TO DO A
PROJECT IN AN ON ONE SIDE BEING
ABLE TO YOU KNOW A WORD
IMMIGRANT FAMILY BUT BEING ABLE
TO TRACE EXACTLY IN MEXICO
WHERE WERE FROM RIGHT I MEAN.
YOU KNOW. AND WE END UP HAVING
TO SUBMIT. TERRIBLY ARE PRIVATE
INFORMATION TO A DNA TEST TO
TRY TO FIND THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE NOBODY IN HER FAMILY ON
THE OTHER SIDE COULD TRACE THAT
AND I KNOW THAT COULD HAPPEN IN
A NON OUT THE AFRICAN FAMILY.
BUT IT TO EVEN TRY TO FIND OUT
WHERE ON A CONTINENT YOUR
ANCESTORS WERE FROM BECAUSE
YOUR HISTORY WAS COMPLETELY
ERASED BY AN INSTITUTION. IT'S
PRETTY POWERFUL AND SO I'M A
LITTLE BIASED IN IN THE AFFECTS
OF THAT NOW. I THINK I LIKE
THIS BILL AND IT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME THIS IS NOTHING
NEW BECAUSE IT CALLS FOR
COMMISSION TO STUDY THIS I MEAN
I MADE AN ANY JERK REACTION
BELIEVE YOU NOW YOUR PROMISE
FORTY ACRES AND A MULE YOU
WOULD OF THEN BUILT WEALTH AND
PASS THAT ON TO GENERATIONS.
THAT IS IN EFFECT AS WELL THERE
IS NO BILL TWELFTH IN SO MANY
OF OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING TO START WITH THEM WHAT
WAS PROMISED WAS TAKEN AWAY.
AND SO THERE ARE A LOT OF A FAX
I THINK THAT WE COULD TALK
ABOUT BUT AGAIN THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS RESOLUTION DOES IT SIMPLY
STATES WE CAN SUPPORT THE IDEA
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STUDY NESS
AND COMING. UP REFEREES. RIGHT
NOT. YES I'M AT BUT REPARATIONS
COULD BE ADMISSIONS RIGHT AND I
KNOW THAT MAY SOUND SILLY WE
CAN SAY THERE'S HISTORY BOOKS
BUT IT SHOULD MISSION OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO SO MANY. FAMILIES
WERE TALK ABOUT SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES AT THE BORDER RIGHT
NOW AND IT REMINDS ME THIS IS
NOTHING NEW IN AND US HISTORY
AND AS AS CONCERNED AS I AM
WITH THOSE KIDS WHAT HAPPENED
IN SLAVE PLANTATIONS IS JUST
SHOCKING AND THE EFFECTS WE
KNOW NOW BECAUSE OF MODERN. YOU
KNOW MEDICINE BASICALLY THAT
THE EFFECTS ON THAT CHILD WILL
WILL AFFECT THAT CHILD AND
POSSIBLY THEIR CHILDREN. THAT
THAT HAPPENED AND THOSE EFFECTS
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT DOWN YOU KNOW
TWO CHILDREN WHO WERE RIPPED
FROM THEIR THEIR MOMS MOMS WHO
BY THE WAY WERE RAPED IN ORDER
TO BEAR THAT CHILD. AND SO I
JUST THINK IT'S TIME IF WE WANT
TO GET PASSED SO MUCH OF THE
DIVISION IN THIS COUNTRY AND
SUMMIT A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHY I'M ARE THE WAY THEY ARE
WE TO BE HONEST BUT THE PACKED
AND I THINK WE START HERE. SURE.
AGAIN WE ARE NINE FIVE SENATORS
EVERY JUST AND I THINK THE CRUX
OF THE THEN IS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT REPARATIONS MAIN
BECAUSE IF WE TALK ABOUT THOSE
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES IN THE
SOCIOLOGICAL CONSEQUENCES YOU
MENTION I COMPLETELY AGREE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT SOCIETY NEEDS TO
ADDRESS A PERSISTENT.
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WEALTH GAP IN
EDUCATION GAP THAT WE THAT
STILL PERSIST IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY I THINK HAS
ITS ROOTS IN SLAVERY I THINK
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE SOCIETY
ADDRESS THAT WE ARE DOING SOME
THINGS WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE.
THE OF WHAT WE DISAGREE ON IS
THAT ARE WHEN I READ H. R. R.
FORTY THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO ME THAT
IT'S NOT ABOUT DECIDING WHETHER
OR NOT REPARATIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE IT'S DECIDING. ARE
ON A METHODOLOGY FOR
APPROPRIATING MONEY AND
DISTRIBUTING IT YOU KNOW IT'S
GONE WAY BEYOND THAT IF THERE'S
AN ASSUMPTION AN HR FORTY I
THINK. THAT REPARATIONS ARE A
GOOD THING AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE A PAUSE ON THAT SO
I'LL BE WERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BUT I JUST
WANTED THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
THAT THAT IS A NEW OCCASION
WHERE 95% WERE IN AGREEMENT AND
WE'RE- DISAGREEING ON TO. HELP
GET THAT LAST 5% THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS. THANK YOU WAS
BECAUSE ALSO I THINK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS FOCUSING ON A
DARK HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY
AND EVEN IN CALIFORNIA ARE
COMPLICITY IN IT HISTORICALLY
BECAUSE AS MR OBERNOLTE IS
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. THE
HOW COME FROM SLAVERY AND DE DE
HUMANIZATION OF AN ENTIRE RACE
OF PEOPLE HAS LED TO A LOT OF
POLICIES THAT PEOPLE TODAY WE
THAT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
TODAY. HOUSING DISCRIMINATION
ECONOMIC DISCRIMINATION WE IT
THIS CASE DISCRIMINATION WE
HAVE SET PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THIS
HISTORIC PATTERN. BEHIND WAY
AND THE REST OF THIS STATE HAS
BEEN MOVING FORWARD THOSE ARE
VERY DIFFICULT QUESTIONS TO
HAVE AND WHAT AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF REPARATIONS ARE OR HOW
WE ADDRESS THOSE ECONOMIC.
DISCRIMINATIONS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IT IS A VERY HARD
QUESTION BUT WE CANNOT HONESTLY
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES IN CALIFORNIA IT
WITHOUT HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION IN FACT IF WE STOP
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
RATES. IN POLICY THEN IT'S THE
RACISTS WHO WINTHOSE
CONVERSATIONS SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTIVE OF IT I
DO APPRECIATE MR CLARK'S.
THOUGHTFUL AND DEEP ANALYSIS OF
THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE OF HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE AND I A IN
SOME IS. IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE
TO APOLOGIZE BUT I DID TRY TO.
YOU WOULD NOT OF SAID YOU
BELIEVE WITH 95% OF MY FIRST
DRAFT OF THE THROAT. HE SAID.
AND I DID REALIZE THAT. WE COME
FROM WE ALL COME FROM THIS AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF HAVING BEEN
INFORMED OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
IT IN THIS I TRIED VERY HARD I
THINK THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING YOU
KNOW THIS THIS WOULD SIMPLY
SUPPORT A BILL THAT WOULD
CREATE A COMMISSION TO SUPPORT
TICKET TO PRODUCE A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WOULD THEN
CREATE MORE YOU KNOW AND WOULD
HAVE TO THEN GO TO THE CONGRESS
AND SO I TRIED TO BE CLEAR.
THAT IT AND YOU KNOW SELECT THE
IN ONE TOWN NOT EVEN SAY THAT
WAS YOU KNOW AN ECONOMIC
REPARATIONS I HONESTLY LIKE
STARTED WITH FORTY ACRES AND A
MULE. PLUS INTEREST. FOOTBALL
AND I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCES SO IN IN THAT SENSE
I DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR THE
RESOLUTION AT ALL I I'M SORRY I
CAN'T GET TO ON THIS BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS AT
LEAST IN THAT RESPECT I RESPECT
LASSEN ABOUT THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS THAT A D. R. TWENTY
ONE BE ADOPTED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAU
CHIU GONZALEZ I CONSULT AYE
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
PETRIE-NORRIS RADIUS. I. WE
NEED TO MORE I'M GONNA PUT THAT
BILL OR THE RESOLUTION ON CALL.
ALRIGHT MR TANG SPRING SAYS TO
AJ ARE TWENTY TWO. OUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HR TWENTY TWO RECOGNIZES
DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN AS A SEVENTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE REPEAL OF
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT AND
ALSO CALLED UPON THE PRESIDENT
TO RESCIND HIS ANTI IMMIGRANT
AND ANTI MUSLIM EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AS YOU RECALL THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT WAS THE
COUNTRY'S FIRST LAW
PROHIBITING. IMMIGRATION SOLELY
ON THE BASIS OF ETHNICITY TO
PREVENT A CHINESE LABORS FROM
ENTERING THE COUNTRY DESPITE
THE MANY YEARS OF THE LABORS
TOILED ON THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD IN THIS IS A VERY
HISTORIC YOUR BECAUSE WE ALSO
CELEBRATING THE HISTORY THE
UNIVERSITY OF THAT
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD AS
WELL. AS WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A
STAIN ON OUR US HISTORY AND
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO REMEMBER THIS ACT
WITHOUT. WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THIS. KEEP THIS PLACE. HI MANY
PLEASE A CHEER FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT EIGHT ARE TWENTY TWO.
ADVANCINGJUSTICE CALIFORNIA'S A
PARTNERSHIP OF THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS AND ADVANCING JUSTICE
LOS ANGELES WE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS OF ASIAN
AMERICAN NATIVE HAWAIIAN.
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND OTHER
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
PROMOTE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
SOCIETY FOR ALL. THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT WAS SIGNED BY
PRESIDENT CHESTER A. ARTHUR ON
MAY SIXTH EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE ACT WAS INITIALLY INTENDED
TO LAST FOR TEN YEARS. BUT IT
WAS RENEWED IN EIGHTEEN NINETY
TWO WITH THE GARY ACT AND THEN
MADE PERMANENT IN NINETEEN OH
TWO. SEVEN YEARS PRIOR TO THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT THE AGE
ACT HAD SET A PRECEDENT BY
BANNING CHINESE WOMAN FROM
IMMIGRATING TO THE US. SO THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT SERVES AS
A REMINDER THAT OUR NATION
HOWEVER INCREMENTALLY UNDER
NATIONALIST AGENDAS. CAN
DECONSTRUCT OUR AMERICAN VALUES
OF FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL IN FAVOR OF. FEAR AND XENA
PHOBIA. AJ ARE TWENTY TWO IS
TIMELY BECAUSE THERE'S NO DOUBT
A LINK BETWEEN THE RACIAL AND
RELIGIOUS ANIMOSITY OF THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT AND
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDERS. TO
DATE PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
SUSPENDED THE ENTRY OF ALL
REFUGEES UNDER THE US REFUGEE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS SOUGHT TO
HAVE THE NUMBER OF ACCEPTED
REFUGEES INTO OUR COUNTRY
SUSPENDED ENTRY OF IMMIGRANTS
AND SOME CLASSES OF NON
IMMIGRANTS FROM SEVERAL
MAJORITY MUSLIM COUNTRIES.
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TO HIRE TEN
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS EMPOWERED
STATES AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO PERFORM
FUNCTIONS OF IMMIGRATION
OFFICERS AND BROADLY EXPANDED
THE CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE
CLASSIFIED AS PRIORITIES FOR
REMOVAL. AS ASIAN AMERICANS WE
CELEBRATE THE REPEAL OF THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT BUT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO WORK TO
DISMANTLE THE RACIST CLASSES
AND ENOUGH OF IT POLICIES THAT
CONTINUE TO PLAGUE OUR COUNTRY.
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WOULD
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION. RIGHT SAY NONE
OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SCOUTER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING FOR THE MEASURE
AYE I THINK THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT IS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE TALKING. A LOT MORE
ABOUT IN ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
WHAT OCCURRED THERE I THINK A
LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT. THAT THIS REALLY CAME
OUT OF CALIFORNIA IN MANY WAYS
AND THAT IT WAS VERY MUCH AN
IMPETUS BEHIND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION OF
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I
BELIEVE IT WAS. WHICH IS STILL
OUR CONSTITUTION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. CAME OUT OF THAT
SAME CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION
IS LARGELY INFLUENCED OUT OF
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE THE WORKING
MAN'S PARTY HAD COME TO POWER
AND DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS. IN
THE STATE WHO WHO PUT THAT INTO
PLACE AND LARGELY BECAUSE THEY-
THEY DID NOT LIKE. THAT CHINESE
IMMIGRANTS CAME HERE AND WORK
FOR LOWER WAGES. THAN
THEMSELVES VERY HIGHLY LABOR
INFLUENCED. INFLUENCE MOVEMENT
AND WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT ALL
THE HISTORY. BEHIND THAT AND
RECOGNIZE THE SINGS FOR WHAT
FOR WHAT IT WAS I THINK WE NEED
TO BRING THOSE ACCURATE
DEPICTIONS OF WHAT OCCURRED
THERE ARE STILL STREETS AND
BUILDINGS IN SAN FRANCISCO
NAMED AFTER SOME OF THESE
FOLKS. WHO ADVOCATED FOR
CHINESE EXCLUSION. I DON'T HEAR
ENOUGH ABOUT THAT YEAH I KNOW
IT FOR A LOT ABOUT DIFFERENT
STATUES AND THINGS. I DON'T
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT IN IN
REGARD TO THIS SO I THINK IT'S
VERY MUCH. APP THAT WE- YOU
KNOW TALK ABOUT THAT HISTORY
AND TALK ABOUT THINGS TODAY. MY
PROBLEM WITH THIS RESOLUTION AS
YOU WILL NOTE OF COURSES THAT I
REALLY DON'T SEE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN WHAT'S GOING ON IN
TERMS OF TRUMP'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS WHICH ARE LARGELY
FOCUSED ON THE SECURITY THREATS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED NOT
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP. BUT BY THE
CIA AND BY OUR SECURITY
AGENCIES. THE SAID HEY THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO IN TERMS OF WHO WE
ARE LET IN OUR COUNTRY FOR
SECURITY PURPOSES NOT BECAUSE
OF WHAT SOMEONE'S RACES ARE
WHAT BECOMES WHAT SOMEONE'S
RELIGION IS. SO I THINK TO
CONFLATE THOSE THINGS TO ME
UNDERMINES. THE VERY REAL
THINGS THAT HAPPENED. IN THAT
HISTORY. AND WHAT WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT AND BE VERY WARY
AGAINST. TRULY XENOPHOBIC ANTI
RELIGIOUS. BIGOTRY THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN OUR PASS AND- I AGREE
WITH THE NEED TO BE EVER
VIGILANT AGAINST IT. BUT I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO USE THIS
AS KIND OF A POLITICAL. AGENDA
I THINK WE NEED TO USE AS A
TEACHING MOMENT AND WE AYE WE
MAY JUST DISAGREE ON THAT AND
THAT'S FINE THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE IN THIS BODY. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION I
THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE IT AND- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THE MEASURE. THE
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS THING NONE
THANK YOU MISTER TANG AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IF WE
DON'T. STATICALLY DISCUSS OUR
PAST WE ARE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT
AND I THINK THAT CONNECTION I
DISAGREE WITH MR GALLAGHER THE
CONNECTION WITH THE EXAMPLES
THAT HE BROUGHT UP ARE EXACTLY
A POINT WITH WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON. THE NATIONAL STAGE RIGHT
NOW WITH THE XENOPHOBIA AND
RELIGIOUS PERSECUTION EVEN
UNDER THE GUISE OF NATURAL
NATIONAL SECURITY WHICH IS
PROVING TO NOT NOT BE TRUE
WHATSOEVER. SO THE LESSONS FROM
THE PAST IF WE DON'T LEARN FROM
THEM AND IF WE DON'T DISCUSS
THEM AND IF WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THEM THAN THOSE WHO WOULD WANT
TO REPEAT THEM AND SUPPORT THE
REPETITION OF THOSE ACTS.
ULTIMATELY WHEN. VISITING YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THANK THE VICE
CHAIR FOR HIS COMMENTS AS WELL
ESPECIALLY THE HOPING PART
WHERE HE OBVIOUSLY DOES
DESCRIBE THE HISTORIC SITUATION
AND THAT HE'S ACTUALLY WRITE
THAT MUCH OF IT DID EMANATE
FROM. SAN FRANCISCO FROM A- FOR
MANY PEOPLE WHO WORK IN LABOR
AND WERE FEARING FOR THEIR ARE
WORKING CLASS JOBS AND SAW
IMMIGRATION AS COMPETITION. AND
MUCH OF THAT TONE IS STILL I
THINK VERY CONSISTENT TODAY
WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF. WORKING
CLASS AMERICANS WORKING CLASS
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN FEAR OF
WHAT'S COMING OR WHAT IS HERE
AND HOW IT IMPACTS THEIR
LIVELIHOOD THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK AND- MAKE A LIVING IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW PUT A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS IN TO SUPPORT
THE FAMILY THESE ARE ALL. I'M
VERY NORMAL I THINK INSTINCTS I
THINK WHAT. WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL OFF. AND I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS OF ANY
PARTICULAR SITUATION BUT- WILL
BE SEEN IS IN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WHEN WE- ARE BROAD BRUSH
OR OR TAKE A BRUSH TO A GROUP
OF PEOPLE. WERE WITH THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE HOUSE NATIONAL
SECURITY AND WE HAVE ALL THESE
COMPACT TO REGRET. IT IN A
PROGRAM THAT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION SHOP. CAN
BE HEARD. HE IS THE PRESENTER
TALK ABOUT THAT IT'S OKAY TO
TALK ABOUT SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DANGEROUS AND YOU WOULD
HAVE MY FULL SUPPORT I THINK
EVERYONE'S FULL SUPPORT THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUAL SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED OUR COUNTRY WE SHOULD
BE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO. ON PREVENT THEIR ENTRANCE
HAVING SAID THAT TO HAVE A
BROAD CATEGORY OF ANY PEOPLE.
REGARDLESS OF YOU KNOW WHO THEY
ARE AND WE'VE SEEN THIS OVER
AND OVER TIME WE ARE WE'VE HAD.
IRISH IMMIGRANTS ITALIAN
IMMIGRANTS VERY. VARIOUS GROUPS
OF PEOPLE IN THEIR EARLY.
STAGES OF THEIR IMMIGRATION WHO
WERE PAINTED WITH. A BRUSH THAT
WAS ANTI AMERICAN AND WHAT
WE'VE COME TO. SEE IS THAT
REALLY WERE ALL AMERICAN NO
MATTER WHERE WE COME FROM WHO
WE ARE BECAUSE WE ALL. BELIEVE
IN THE AMERICAN PRINCIPLE WE
ALL WANT TO BE PART OF THIS
AMERICAN DREAM AND THAT
ULTIMATELY IS REALLY WHAT HOLD
OUR COUNTRY. WITH THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AJ ARE TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTION IS THAT A
JUROR TWENTY TO BE ADOPTED
KALRA PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
CHAO. CHAU AYE CHU GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN IN CHINA I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES. YES I.
TWENTY TWO MORE I WILL ALSO PUT
THAT ONE ON CALL THANK YOU AS
WE WAIT FOR MISS WICKS WE DO
HAVE ONE ITEM ON CONSENT THAT
IS H. R. FORTY FOUR OF TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CONSENT. HI
GALLAGHER I CHAO CHAO AYE CHIU
GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS.
SO THEY CAN IT CONSENT AGENDA
IS ADOPTED THAT IS H. R. FORTY
FOUR IS ADOPTED ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TAKES US TO OUR LAST
ITEM ACR ONE TEN THIS WEEK'S.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED TO MAKE
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY GUARANTEEING
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY INCLUDING
THE CHOICE ON WHETHER TO
TERMINATE A PREGNANCY
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT STATE LAWS
THAT RESTRICT ABORTION HAVE
BECOME SO EXTREME THAT THEY
THREATEN THE RIGHTS OF THOSE
WHO LIVE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
THEIR BORDERS. ADDITIONALLY
MANY OF THE STATES THAT HAVE
PASSED EXTREME ABORTION BAN
LAWS AND TWENTY NINETEEN HAVE
AMONG THE HIGHEST MATERNAL AND
INFANT MORTALITY RATES IN THE
COUNTRY SUCH RESTRICTIONS WILL
FURTHER ENDANGER WOMEN'S HEALTH
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME WOMEN
INDIVIDUALS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WHO ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY RESTRICTING ACCESS
TO ABORTION CARE AS ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE START
NATIONALLY CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
BY STANDING UP. FOR
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL
PEOPLE. ACR ONE TEN IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION. BY DECLARING
CALIFORNIA A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE FOR ALL ACR ONE
TEN WILL REAFFIRM OUR STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO GUARANTEEING THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY. IT'S TO
FULLY PROTECTED RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION FOR WOMEN AND PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS I WILL HAVE MY
WITNESS SELF INTRODUCED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR SUCH AS
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS AMY EVERITT I AM THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF SPECIAL
PROJECTS IN A ROW PRO CHOICE
AMERICA. AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR STATE DIRECTOR
SHANNON HOPE IT. NARAL PRO
CHOICE AMERICA IS THE
GRASSROOTS NATIONAL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZING. OF REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
TWO POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
HEARING CALIFORNIA. IN EVERY
COUNTY. COULD YOU SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE MICROPHONE SO
WE HAVE YOU ON OUR RECORD. WITH
THAT HE BETTER. THANK YOU YES.
AT NAY ROW WE DON'T OPERATE AND
WE DON'T LITIGATE. WE LEAVE
THAT TRY ALLY THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND THE ACLU. WE
ORGANIZE AND WE MOBILIZED TO
LIKE PRO CHOICE CANDIDATES AND
HAVE PROACTIVE PRO CHOICE
LEGISLATION. NEVER WORKS TO
GUARANTEE THAT EVERY PERSON HAS
THE RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS REGARDING THE FULL
RANGE OF REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES.
INCLUDING PREVENTING UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY. BEARING HEALTHY
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN ABORTION
CARE. BUT LET'S BE REAL ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN. IN THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAVE PACKED THE
FEDERAL JUDICIARY INCLUDING THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
WITH ANTI CHOICE STRUCTURE. AND
STATE LEGISLATORS ARE
RESPONDING TO THE REALITY. THAT
THE PROTECTIONS OF ROE VERSUS
WADE WILL BE OVERTURNING GOT
IT. CRIMINALIZING AND PUNISHING
WOMEN WHO ACCESS THE PORTION
CARE AND THE DOCTORS WHO
PROVIDE THAT CARE. ALREADY
THIRTY STATES HAVE TAKEN STEPS
TO BAN ABORTION WHETHER IT IS
AN OHIO AND GEORGETTE WITH
BANDS THAT SIX WEEKS OR DAYS
TENNESSEE AND ALABAMA WHICH
TOTALED ABORTION BANS WITH NO
EXCEPTIONS FOR RAPE OR INCEST.
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS ALL THE RELENTLESSLY
ATTACKED WOMEN'S DIGNITY TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISION FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY.
MOST RECENTLY THEY HAVE IMPOSED
A DOMESTIC GAG RULE. ON ACT
FIFTEEN ABORTION CARE AT BIRTH
AT PLACES THAT DEFENSE BIRTH
CONTROL INTERFERING BETWEEN THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP. SO
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THE FIGHT FOR LEGAL AND SAFE
ABORTION CARE. WE HAVE BEEN
LEADING POLICIES TO EXPAND
ACCESS AND ENSURE DIGNITY AND
HEALTH CARE FOR THOSE WHO
CONTINUE PREGNANCIES AND THOSE
WHO TERMINATE PREGNANCIES. BUT
IF THE OTHER STATES AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CONTINUE
TO THROW UP OBSTACLES TO
ABORTION CARE AMBER AND TO
BIRTH CONTROL ACCESS WOMEN AND
PREGNANT PEOPLE WILL TURN TO
THE PEAK AND THAT IS
CALIFORNIA. MANY PERJURY STATES
ARE STEPPING UP TO MEET THE NEW
REALITY IF A POST ROH WORLD AND
CALIFORNIA AGAIN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD. THE
RESOLUTION TO DECLARE
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
STATE FOR ALL. IT'S A POWERFUL
STEP TO FOLLOW GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM'S PROCLAMATION A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. AND IT IS
THE PROMISE THAT WE WILL DOUBLE
DOWN TO ENSURE. THAT
REPRODUCTIVE ACCESS IS EXPANDED
AND SUPPORTED. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE BEST
PRO CHOICE LIFE IN THE COUNTRY
WE CAN STILL DO MORE. WE HAVE
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THANK YOU BUT
POLICIES PASSED IN SACRAMENTO
THAT WOMEN AND PREGNANT PEOPLE
ON THE STREET DON'T KNOW ABOUT
DON'T MATTER WE HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF ENSURING. THAT
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE AND WHAT THEIR ACCESS TO
LOOK LIKE. 43% OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTY HOSPITAL ABORTION
CLINIC. WHICHMEANS THAT THERE
ARE WEEKS AND MONTHS WE'LL
WAITING PERIODS BEFORE WOMEN
AND PREGNANT PEOPLE CAN ACCESS
CARE NO MATTER WHERE HEY ARE
WHETHER IT IS IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES. OR IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
SOME CALIFORNIA HAVE TO TRAVEL
MORE THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILES ACCESS CARE. SO LET'S BE
CLEAR SEVEN IN TEN AMERICANS
SUPPORT THE LEGAL ACCESS TO
ABORTION. THIS CUTS ACROSS. ALL
STATE. ALL POLITICAL PARTY
LINE. ALL RELIGIOUS LINES ALSO
SHOW ECONOMIC LEVELS ALL RACIAL
LEVELS. EIGHT IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA EEL THE SAME WAY
AND EITHER EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
PERSONALLY OPPOSED TO ABORTION
THEY DO NOT WANT OBSTACLES TO
THAT CARE. WOMEN IN THEIR
FAMILY THE FREEDOM TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS FOR THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY DON'T
DESERVE TO PAY THE PRICE FOR A
POLITICAL AGENDA I AM PROUD TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF EIGHT THE ART
WHEN TEN. AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT SEE NONE AS
THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT SEE
NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU IS TOGETHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR. I THINK THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE THAT'S
VERY CONTROVERSIAL FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND MEN AND OTHERS
SENSITIVE BUT I MEAN I JUST
THINK THE CHARACTERIZATION.
WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING AND
I THINK LARGE THE WHAT. THEY'RE
FOCUSING IN ON HIS THIRD
TRIMESTER ABORTIONS. AND ROW
ITSELF ACTUALLY LAID OUT THE
FOUNDATION THAT STATES COULD DO
MORE. IN THAT THIRD TRIMESTER
TO PROTECT WHAT WHAT IS A
VIABLE. FETUS AND TO HAVE THAT
BALANCE. THAT REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN THE RIGHTS OF
THE MOTHER AND THE RIGHTS OF
THE UNBORN CHILD. BI<c.cyan> CARA</c>
CATEGORIZED AS RADICAL I THINK
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE A CARROT
CATEGORIZES RADICAL THIRD
TRIMESTER ABORTIONS. I THINK
THEY WOULD CHARACTERIZE AS
RADICAL THE STATEMENTS OF THE
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR. THAT A BABY
COULD BE EVEN ABORTED EVEN
AFTER IT'S BEEN DELIVERED. YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE VERY RADICAL
THINGS AND I THINK WHAT A LOT
OF THESE STATES ARE TRYING TO
DO IS RECOGNIZE WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE IS THAT. WE ARE
DEALING WITH PROTECTING WOMEN'S
RIGHTS BUT WERE ALSO HAVING TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
LIFE. AT ISSUE HERE AND THAT WE
DO HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR AND ROW
ACTUALLY LAID THAT OUT AND YOU
KNOW THE AND SO LOOK A LOT OF
THAT DISCUSSION I THINK NEEDS
TO HAPPEN. I THINK IT SHOULD
HAPPEN AND PRODUCTIVE ANNA. IN
A REASONED AWAY YOU KNOW. AS
OPPOSED TO A REAL ANTAGONISTIC
WAY AS IT TENDS TO END UP. BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE I ALSO YOU KNOW.
I FIND IT A LITTLE BIT FOR NAY
ROUTE TO COME IN HERE AND SAY
SOME OF THOSE THINGS WHEN THEY
PARTICULARLY HAVE GONE AFTER
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS IN THE
STATE AND VIOLATED ATTEMPTED TO
VIOLATE THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. THEY ARE RUNNING
LEGISLATURE AND WE COULD STAY
ON THE TITLE WERE IT NOT GO
AFTER THE WE ARE ON TOP OF
THESE ISSUES THIS COMMITTEE
CONSIDERED AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
TWO YEARS AGO WHICH WAS
DESIGNED TO SHUT DOWN THE
SPEECH RIGHTS. AND ABILITY OF
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS WHO I
KNOW FOR A FACT. OUR WITH WOMEN
ON THE STREET EVERY DAY HELPING
THEM TO CRISIS PREGNANCIES AND
HAVE BEEN A GREAT RESOURCE. TO
PEOPLE. AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S ONLY THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU AGREE WITH.
THAT YOU WANT TO TRY AND HELP
PROMOTE AND ADVOCATE FOR BUT
YOU'RE PERFECTLY FINE TAKEN
AWAY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. OF
OTHERS WHO MAYBE DON'T SHARE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE A PRO LIFE
GROUPS BUT VERY MUCH CARE ABOUT
WOMEN WHO ARE IN CRISIS
PREGNANCIES. AND SO YOU CAN'T
REALLY HAVE IT BOTH WAYS NOW
CAN YOU. AND I THINK WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD STAND UP FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF ALL
PEOPLE. AND SO YOU KNOW I JUST
I'D. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
WAY THIS IS BEING CHARACTERIZED
IS NOT ACCURATE AS ALL IS ON
SALE. THIS CAR. ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD AND TO
CHARACTERIZE WHAT OTHER STATES
ARE DOING IS SIMPLY HAVING A
DEBATE. OVER THE TIME. OF THE
IT IS I THINK THE REQUEST THE
REALITY IS THEY WANT TO HAVE
ABORTION BAN THEY WANT TO TAKE
CHOICE AWAY FROM WOMEN THEY'RE
TAKING FUNDING AWAY THERE'S
MANY STATES. WE TALK ABOUT THE
LACK OF ACCESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE SOME STATES
WERE A YET TO LITERALLY GO
OTHER STATE. IN ORDER TO GET
THE CLOSEST MOST CONVENIENT
TEST. I AND SO. AND. IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR WOMEN IT
SHOULD BE THERE RIGHT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW WHAT ALL
THE OPTIONS ARE BEFORE THEM.
AND IT'S VERY SCARY BECAUSE
THIS COMING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE ALL THE WAY DOWN. THE
EFFORTS TO TRY TO TAKE AWAY A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND
THAT'S ALL THAT'S WHAT THIS
COMES DOWN TO. IS EITHER WE
BELIEVE IN TRUSTS WOMEN ARE NOT
AND FRANKLY AND MOST OF THE
STATE'S AND INCLUDING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IS OUR MAN FOR
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS. AND
ADMITS APPALLING. AND SO IT'S
EASY TO TALK ABOUT IT AS SOME
KIND OF POLITICAL DEBATE AND
WHAT HAVE YOU THE REALITY IS
THAT WOMEN'S LIVES ARE ON THE
LINE WITH HIS CHOICE IS BEING
STRIPPED AWAY. AND IT WILL BE
HERE IN A VERY DANGEROUS PLACE
AS IT APPLIES TO LOOK TO A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE RIGHT
NOW. AND SO DEBT TO SOMEHOW
CHARACTERIZED AS. I THINK
MISSES THE BOAT ALL TOGETHER
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S WOMEN
THAT ARE BEING TARGETED IN MANY
WAYS THIS IS ONE OF A MINUTE
WHAT ONE SIGNIFICANT WAY IN
WHICH WOMEN ARE BEING TARGETED.
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION AND BY
MANY STATES AND EVEN PEOPLE IN
OUR OWN STATE APPARENTLY SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS AND HOPE
THAT WE ALL CAN AGREE THAT A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE. IS
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT AND
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE OF
INVADING THEIR PRIVACY AND
THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE THE RIGHT
CHOICE FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILY. THANK YOU MR AURA THE
COMMENTS HE HAS WORKED FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND I THINK
THAT MIS CHARACTERIZATIONS THAT
ARE OBVIOUSLY CONTINUING SO THE
DESPERATE NEED FOR A CLEAR
STATEMENT SAYING CLEAR
DIRECTION ON DEALING WITH
REPRODUCTIVE CARE ABORTION
SERVICES AND WOMEN'S HEALTH
WHICH IS GETTING RIGHT NOW VERY
VERY MUCH OFF TRACK IN THIS
COUNTRY SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MY COLLEAGUE MADE YOU KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND WHEN WE
SEE THESE LAWS IN OTHER STATES
LIKE ALABAMA WHICH IS OUTLAWED
ABORTION INCLUDE AT AT ALL
LEVELS INCLUDING IN THE CASE OF
RAPE INCEST THAT IS NOT ABOUT
THIRD TRIMESTER ABORTIONS TO BE
VERY CLEAR. AND SO AS A WOMAN
WHO'S HAD AN ABORTION WHEN I
WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND I
WAS LIVING AT A FRIEND'S HOUSE
AND I DON'T HAVE A JOB. I WAS
IN A DESPERATE MOMENT. THAT IS
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU HAVE EVER
BEEN IN. AND I NEEDED THE
ABILITY TO ACT TO EXERCISE MY
RIGHT IN A MOMENT. AND THERE'S
THAT WOMEN ALABAMA RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO THE SAME EXACT
THING. FOR US TO BE A BEACON OF
HOPE YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
PROTECT THOSE RIGHT. IS WHAT
THESE RESOLUTIONS ABOUT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK.
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS THAT A C.
R. ONE TEN BE ADOPTED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHOW I CHEW. CONSOLES HOLDEN
CHOLERA. COLORADO I KYLIE KYLIE
NO MAIN CHINA MAN CHINA NIGHT
OVER NOTI OVERNIGHT YOU KNOW
PETER NORRIS RACE. RACE I. THAT
NEEDS TO MORE WILL PLACE THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE THREE
BILLS ON CALL SO IF WE COULD
GET THE APPS THE MEMBERS TO
SHOW UP HI I KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE. MOVING AROUND AND IN
DIFFERENT PLACES SO WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A LITTLE
WHILE HOPING WE CAN GET
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS TO CAST A
BOOK TO BE ABLE TO CAST A VOTE.
ALL RIGHTS SO THOSE WHO. OKAY
WELL LET'S SINCE WE HAVE A
COUPLE LET'S ROLL THROUGH THESE
ITEMS STARTING WITH CONSENT IF
YOU CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS TWO
HI TWO I CAN SELL AS HOLDEN.
BETWEEN NORRIS PETER NORTH I
RAISE. RATES I THANK YOU THAT
IS ALREADY OUT SO A C. R. ONE
TEN BY WICKS'S ON CALL IN A
LIFT THE CALL CALL IT THE
MEMBERS TO. CHEW I CONDOLENCE
HOLDEN. PETER NORTH NORTH SIDE.
THAT RESOLUTION IS OUT I AG ARE
TWENTY ONE BY GONZALES OUR ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS ON CALLING WITH A
LIFT THE CALL CHOW. CHOW I CHEW
I HOLD IN PETER NORTH. THAT
RESOLUTION. IS ADOPTED THAT IS
OUT AJ ARE TWENTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER THREE BY TANG IS ALL
CALL ME TO LIFT THE CALL TO.
CHEW I CONDOLENCE HOLDEN. PETER
NORRIS NORTH SIDE. THAT IS ALSO
OUT TO ALL OF OUR BUSINESS IS
COMPLETE I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HOLD WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR A LITTLE WHILE
LONGER WE COULD CALL THOSE
OFFICES IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND COMPLETE. THEIR
VOTING THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED
. RIGHT MR HOLDEN SO
CAN SCENT WHICH IS H. R. FORTY
FOUR MISTER CHO GONZALEZ
HOLDEN HOLD A NIGHT THANK YOU
THEN A SPARE ONE TEN WICKS IN
DALLAS HOLDEN. HOLD A NIGHT. AJ
ARE TWENTY ONE GONZALEZ HOLDEN.
THE NIGHT AND AJ ARE TWENTY TWO
TANG GONZALEZ HOLDEN CALL THE
NIGHT. THANK YOU PERFECT ALL
RIGHT BACK COMPLETES OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED